you're assuming as a notion of privacy I
mean I was with a publisher of a major
news media site today and we were
talking about privacy and you know he we
were saying that if we went out in the
street and you asked 100 people about
about privacy or cookies or whatever
they wouldn't even know I mean it just
so I think the vast majority of people
even educated people don't have a sense
for the data that that's being collected
about them and that's being used for
them used to target at them in positive
and negative ways I think there's an
awareness of spyware and you know
viruses and things of that nature
because it's very much in your face but
you know just simple things like you
know how your data is being using all
these websites or what you're you know
what right you have that data and to get
that data out of that system even if you
want it people have no awareness of and
it's going to I think it's going to take
a 911 type of event for privacy to
really shake people that you know that
shakes people today accord and recognize
they gotta pay attention to this and
then and only then I think will they
take responsibility that the terrorism
model is probably right if you you know
if you saw five young guys on a plane
dispersed around the airplane that we're
kind of doing suspicious things you
would pay attention to it and you would
and you would maybe tell us the flight
attendant and you would and obviously
god forbid if they did something I think
that the likelihood of us having another
attack exactly the same way that those
guys did it is impossible there's too
many people on too many planes that
would try to stop them because we saw
the movie already I think that and we
have an awareness now about terrorism
that we didn't have before same thing I
think happens with privacy I think it's
going to be going to be some sort of 911
event that takes place that wears its
some giant breach that affects a lot of
people of some kind whether it be maybe
it's with the government or maybe it's
with you know a major bank where I mean
literally people will lose their
livelihoods or whatever that will shake
people to their core and recognize it
okay I now going to take privacy into my
own hands as
the user and and and and do something
about it
no I haven't seen any i mean i think
that the would i know that everyone's
worried about is google but they seem to
be they seem to be doing an incredible
job with with how they let you export
your data pretty much any data you put
into google you can either delete or
export easily which they can't decide
you for facebook you know there's no way
for you to export your address book on
facebook if you want to if you if you
end your relationship your facebook and
say i want to leave my cat I think
there's been some problems with that in
the past but you can do that now pretty
easily but if you want to take you know
those connections with you and that
contact information with you or your
photos with you good luck you're not
going to do that Google is doing a
better job of that but I think we're
going to see those expectations rise or
people are going to want to want to have
more the data exportable and I haven't
seen some you know company that are
really like nefarious doing stuff
because I think that stuff just gets
outed in a hurry and but it's more the
stuff that's being collected behind your
back Chicago